if you and i have less disposable income  we spend less  if we spend less  there's a lower business profits  if there's lower business profits than  companies layoff which you're going to  see here in a minute what companies are  laying people off  if there's layoffs there's unemployment  by the way i'll take this a little bit  more  when there is unemployment which we  haven't hit yet  then there is foreclosures and  bankruptcies when there's foreclosures  and bankruptcies then what do we have  divorce after divorce we have alcohol  drugs etc etc then crime goes up you see  how the cycle goes believe me no  president wants to do get to get to that  point this is why they try to prevent it  from getting to that point but this is a  cyclical cycle you make less money you  spend less you spend less companies make  less companies make less they let people  go people are fired or laid off  unemployment goes up that's a problem  okay and we're just at the beginning  today